we're still trying to catch up with all
our bills
and trying to keep our hats
above the water lea ulianti owns a
beauty salon in the southwest valley and
says the pandemic has slashed profits
there by 50 percent to the statewide
directives adding even more of a burden
i have to make sure that you know all of
our clients
and my staff are stay safe during the
procedure
and we're following the guidelines the
new regulation and that costs money
the good news is some businesses are
currently being approved for the
pandemic emergency technical support or
pets grant a program specifically meant
to help nevada small businesses
we expect most businesses will have
their funding in the next few weeks
nevada state treasurer's at conine tells
me 3 000 businesses have been approved
so far
a majority of them getting the maximum
10 thousand dollar amount
that means roughly 30 million of the
total 40 million dollars available
is allocated applications have been
closed for over a month and while conan
is hoping another federal recovery
package will put more money in the pet's
pot
he's encouraging struggling businesses
to contact his office in the meantime
we're getting their information and
we've got a database going
so that if additional programs do come
out either
statewide or for specific industries or
in specific areas we can quickly contact
those businesses round three of clark
county stabilization grant is also now
open juliante is working on that
application right now anything helps
during this tough time
companies can apply for up to 30
thousand dollars through the county
stabilization grant
we have more details about that as well
as the contact information
for the nevada state treasurer's office
on our website 8newsnow.com
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now